you have to pay for the domain
acquisition.com was it expensive yeah it
was 400 okay not that bad actually i
looked at marketing.com it was 5.6
million i told layla i sent her a
proposal i price anchored with
marketing.com and then i was like we
could also get acquisition.com which is
400 she's like well that seems much more
reasonable the reason i ended up doing
acquisition wasn't even for the money is
because the type of people and portfolio
companies that i am looking for use the
word acquisition everyone knows what the
word marketing means people who are
trying to scale their companies talk
about cost of acquisition it also had
the double entendre of we you know
acquire stakes in the companies in
addition to helping with acquisition so
i kind of like that component though
yeah 400 i mean it seems like a seal
because five or six years ago zuckerberg
bought fb.com for like eight million
dollars or something like that probably
also a great deal
in retrospect yeah